no father
my generals in killing my wife
humanity has proven to me that they
don't deserve the earth we will scour
them after my father he's gone mad and
now he's going to destroy the world a
world without humans
under endless light
my god Dracula has to be destroyed we
can't fail
No
hey everybody its Charlie they finally
dropped a proper trailer for Castlevania
Season 2 so we gotta break it down if
you're brand new to the channel be sure
to subscribe to get all the videos
there's actually a lot of really cool
stuff coming up from Netflix anime is
kind of their secret weapon now but
they're also working on that new witcher
TV series but they're not even gonna be
shooting that till later this year and
it'll probably take them another year to
get it out so it could be 2020 before we
see that but if you're not familiar with
the Castlevania series the plot of this
is based mostly on the plot of the
Castlevania 3 game because it primarily
follows
Trevor Belmont and his adventure to take
down Dracula who's an ancestor to the
original Simon Belmont from the
beginning of the series the project
itself has a really interesting history
it started out as a movie when that fell
through they decided to turn it into a
TV series so that's why season 1 is only
four episodes because that's basically
the movie that they expand it a little
bit and they just dropped it on Netflix
as a series then because it turned out
so awesome and people liked it so much
they renewed it for season 2 but doubled
the order so season 2 is 8 episodes much
closer to a proper series but the events
of season 1 are mostly Dracula meeting
his wife them having Alucard in him
trying to live life as a normal human
like she inspires him to be a better
person because there's this little
prequel where she finds him at the
beginning of the series enters his
castle seeking knowledge to become a
healer he just completely flabbergasted
it ends up falling in love with her I've
known you two minutes and you offer for
me to walk the earth like an ordinary
peasant while I give you the knowledge
of immortals the true science
[Music]
they have Alucard but then later as he
sort of traveling the land around the
church burns her as a witch because part
of the twist of season one is that the
bishop is the real enemy the church
itself is kind of an antagonist but not
the entire church just through this
particular bishop they don't throw them
all under the bus but as they're burning
her at the stake some of the other
church officials are questioning it like
you know well maybe she wasn't quite so
bad but the bishop played by matt free
where his voice is very recognizable
it's just like nope she's done burner
burn at the stake all of our problems
are her fault we'll burn her it'll solve
everything
so Dracula finds out in declares war on
all of humanity
starting with pilikia
so season one is him summoning the night
horde in the beginning of their attack
season two seems like there's a bit of a
time jump and you get to meet all the
generals so the name of Dracula's army
is the night horde it's huge it has its
own generals its own power structure you
see some of the different beasts that
they employ you see them tinkering with
bodies infusing them with demonic energy
so there's just like a whole side of
this that you didn't get with season one
because it was only four episodes the
only real Knight horde characters that
we meet are right at the end when Trevor
is defeating these last hellhounds and
they speak to the bishop before they
take him down and the rest of the town
starts to burn to ashes it seems like
Dracula's generals are collecting the
bodies after that battle so the beasts
that they defeated in the finale were
really just the beginning like that's
what they say we have an army you have
no idea how big the Horde is and then
they promptly fall into a Locard's tomb
wake him up and form their alliance and
then it just cuts to the credits between
showing off Dracula's generals they show
a couple different encounters here like
it opens on this snowy little town it's
them just travelling through they
probably just come upon some of the
night horn but you have to imagine that
Dracula is just going from town to town
this much larger town looks a little bit
like well lakeya but it could be another
town but the whole idea is that Dracula
intends to wipe humanity from the entire
earth so it's just expanding from season
1 season 1 was largely contained to like
one or two small towns I tried to check
the IMDB they haven't officially
announced who the voice cast is for
these new characters playing Dracula's
generals but the animation is fantastic
this is actually a project from one of
my former bosses Fred Seibert at
Frederator but they're a couple
different Studios involved in producing
this they already announced actually
through Richard Armitage I think without
intending to that they were gonna do a
season 3 it had been backed or renewed
and they were gonna be recording stuff
really soon
but this is mostly just because it takes
so long to get animation this complex
out there
joke that one of the animators had that
there are more lines in Trevor's mouth
than in all of Steven universe's head
which he tried to explain wasn't a dig
on Steven universe he wasn't trying to
make fun of that series this is that
some animation is designed to be more
simple some is more complex Castlevania
because of what they were doing with the
series demanded more complex animation
which itself is actually inspired by a
symphony of the night so the plot is
mostly Castlevania three but the design
is mostly Symphony of the Night which as
you can tell is fantastic so there are
only four episodes in season 1 if you
have not watched it yet or you haven't
watched the billion more times I
recommend checking it out the
interesting thing about Castlevania 3 if
you haven't played it is that there are
actually four separate endings to that
game so I'm interested to see how they
incorporate that into the series however
many seasons it winds up going for anime
typically doesn't get that many episodes
compared to traditional Western
animations so hopefully they'll make it
to like four or five seasons at least
but I'll be curious to see if they
incorporate any of those four separate
endings from the original game or if
it's some sort of twist on that because
yes they do eventually defeat Dracula
like that's the whole idea of the game
is that you're supposed to be Dracula
you crumble his castle but there are so
many Castlevania games as part of the
series that deal with Dracula as the
antagonist so you just wonder how
they're gonna treat that in the Canon
because eventually I think the idea is
that Simon Belmont hundreds of years
later is born he also fights Dracula but
I'm not expecting that to really be a
big part of the series because travel
Belmont will be the primary protagonist
for however long this runs for so let me
know in the comments what you thought of
season 1 what you think of this trailer
so far the official premiere date is
Halloween later this year which seems
appropriate
Netflix drop more Ironfist season 2
there was a whole bunch of Avenger stuff
there's more stuff left over from Comic
Con so I'll try to get through all the
videos as fast as possible leave all
your video requests in the comments
below
but click here to learn about that big
Disney buy out of box that went through
yesterday and click here to rewatch the
Dragon Ball super movie trailer thank
you so much for watching everybody stay
awesome
I'll see you guys tonight
[Music]